schön dass er dabei sein zdf heute live
heute haben so viele menschen die
flugreise einer politikerin verfolgt
dass die website radar zwischenzeitlich
nicht mehr aufgerufen werden konnte ich
zeige euch das kurz hier auf meinem
bildschirm dass der tweet von flight
radar und ihr könnt eben hier auch sehen
die flugroute und zwischenzeitlich waren
über 300.000 menschen live dabei und
haben eben hier bei flight radar diesen
flug verfolgen wollen wer saß drin drin
saß nancy pelosi die vorsitzende des
us-repräsentantenhauses sie ist auf
asienreise und sie hat und das ist heute
besonders auch einen stopp in taiwan
gemacht dort ist sie vor rund drei
stunden gelandet und warum das so viele
menschen heute interessiert und
beschäftigt hat und vor allem warum dass
china so sehr provoziert darum geht es
heute bei uns in der sendung eskaliert
der taiwan konflikt das ist unser thema
ihr könnt fragen stellen kommentieren
per mail oder direkt im stream und ich
versuche so viele davon in dieser
sendung mit unseren experten zu
beantworten was bislang passiert ist in
diesem ganzen thema und wie china auf
diesen besuch reagiert das zeigt erstmal
unser china korrespondent ulf röller
die ersten bilder von nancy pelosi
ankunft in taiwans hauptstadt taipeh ein
umstrittener ein gefährlicher besuch der
die beiden weltmächte china amerika in
einen konflikt treibt wie gefährlich
diese reise ist zeigen diese
veröffentlichten videos des chinesischen
verteidigungsministeriums
die armee probe für den ernstfall auch
für eine invasion taiwans eine warnung
an die usa
ein solcher besuch ist offensichtlich
sehr gefährlich er untergräbt den
frieden und die stabilität in der region
die antwort der chinesen ließ nicht
lange auf sich warten das
verteidigungsministerium kündigt eine
viertägige militärübung an in der taiwan
umzingelt wird
die taiwanesen bereiten sich schon seit
längerem auf das schlimmste vor
probealarm in der hauptstadt die
menschen üben den notfall eines angriffs
der chinesen es herrscht ein gefühl in
der stadt zwischen hoffen und bangen
ich glaube bei einem konflikt stehen die
usa auf unserer seite
der besuch kommt zu einer heiklen zeit
egal wie man sich verhält es gibt kein
richtig oder falsch
vor der küste taiwans belauern sich die
usa und china für pekings machthaber ist
die insel ein teil der volksrepublik die
usa haben ihren flugzeugträger uss
ronald reagan in die region geschickt
sie empfinden sich als schutzmacht
taiwans es ist ein duell der weltmächte
sollte china eine krise anzetteln oder
die situation eskalieren lassen dann ist
peking daran schuld wir erwarten von
ihnen sich verantwortungsvoll zu
verhalten
taiwan hofft auf amerikas helfe das land
heißt die vorsitzende polos sie
willkommen ein herzlicher empfang für
einen besuch der eine ganze region in
die krise stürzen
wir sprechen gleich noch mit einem
experten für chinesische politik aber
zuerst mit unserem korrespondenten in
den usa mit el mati wissen hallo
hallo nach deutschland
wieso hat sich nancy pelosi jetzt zu
diesem zeitpunkt für diese reise
entschieden die jetzt so ein großes echo
hat und china tatsächlich sehr
provoziert hat
ja ich glaube nancy pelosi wollte ein
politisches zeichen setzen weil in den
letzten jahren massiv auch die
militärischen provokationen in der
region sich verstärkt haben durch china
beispielsweise immer wieder dringen
chinesische kampfjets in die schutzzone
um taiwan ein teil warnt fühlt sich
dadurch bedroht auch andere staaten in
der region durch eine weitere
militarisierung china baut stützpunkte
im südchinesischen meer beispielsweise
aus auf atollen die dann mit sand
aufgeschüttet und zement zu lande und
startbahnen zu militärbasen gemacht
werden da wollte sie ein zeichen setzen
weil andere staaten tatsächlich auch
erpresst werden durch china eben durch
den wirtschaftlichen einfluss den china
hat jetzt kommt das aber sie hatte
diesen besuch schon geplant im april und
damals vor ein paar monaten da hat china
sich nicht so sehr darüber aufgeregt
obwohl schon hinweise darauf vorhanden
waren dass sie auch nach taipeh fliegen
würde dann musste sie diesen besuch
absagen aufgrund einer krone erkrankung
jetzt eben ein paar monate später auf
einmal ist das hier das große politische
thema und man liest dass hier in
washington so dass china offenbar und
allen voran shipping der präsident so
innenpolitisch unter druck steht dass er
eigentlich nicht zulassen kann dass das
einfach so hingenommen wird wenn die
dritthöchste frau im amerikanischen
staat teilehandel sucht und damit
natürlich ein signal setzt wir haben
eben gerade als du geantwortet hast
schon bilder gesehen und das waren
bilder von einem video was also das
chinesische militär zeigt einen ja ein
propagandavideo natürlich was die stärke
dieses militärs auch zeigen soll gibt es
denn keine sorge seitens der usa dass
dieser besuch jetzt also china so sehr
provoziert dass da auch eine reaktion
folgen könnte
ja die sorge ist natürlich groß man hat
ja noch einmal in den letzten monaten
immer wieder chinesische militär
provokation gesehen und immer die sorge
gehabt wenn ein großes geschwader von
kampfjets dann in diese schutzzone um
taiwan einfliegt dass es dazu
zwischenfällen kommen könnte und dass
dann eine eskalation passiert die man
vielleicht gar nicht wollte genau das
könnte jetzt wieder passieren und
deswegen versucht das weiße haus er
zweierlei einerseits stellt man das
ganze so da es sei ja nicht so was
besonderes wenn eben politiker
kongressabgeordnete nach taiwan reisen
das ist in der tat in den letzten
monaten mehrfach der fall gewesen dass
delegation des kongresses in taiwan
waren und es würde nicht so sagt das
weiße haus ändern an der sogenannten ein
china politik also der politik die davon
ausgeht dass es nur ein china gibt dass
die haupt vertretung für dieses china in
peking setzt die regierung dort ist aber
diese regelung auch beinhaltet dass das
chinesische volk also chinesische
chinesische bürger auf beiden seiten der
straße von taiwan friedlich und frei
entscheiden können wie sie oder wie sie
nicht zusammenleben wollen daran hält
man fest das zweite was man versucht ist
auch ein stück weit klarzumachen was
alles kaputt geht wenn es zu einer
militärischen eskalation käme denn in
der tat haben die beiden usa und china
große wirtschaftspolitische interessen
nicht nur in der region sondern weltweit
wenn es eine eskalation gäbe dann würden
die handelswege massiv betroffen sein in
dieser region es würden beispielsweise
die hightech produkte die man braucht
die teilweise halbleiter und mikrochips
herstellung brauchen in dieser region
die würden dann werden das heißt auf die
schwierige wirtschaftslage der welt
würde noch eine erschwerte lage hinzu
kommen und man will ja auch miteinander
zusammenarbeiten letzte woche hat jean
ping 2 stunden 20 minuten mit joe biden
telefoniert da ging es auch um viel
konstruktives man wollte zusammenarbeit
im kampf gegen den klimawandel oder
gegen pandemien in der zukunft all das
könnte natürlich jetzt kaputt gehen wenn
es in den nächsten tagen zu einer
militärischen eskalation käme es gab
schon medienberichte dass zumindest
chinesische militärflugzeuge heute sehr
nah an der neutralen zone zu teheran
geflogen sein soll auch das teil
taiwanesischer militär hat wohl die
bereitschaft erhöht und da haben wir
auch ein bild wie der aussieht hat die
die usa hat vier kriegsschiffe östlich
von taiwan hat hat die usa dahin
geschickt darunter auch den
flugzeugträger den usa ronald reagan und
jetzt wäre die frage aber was hat das zu
bedeuten dass die usa da jetzt aber auch
kriegsschiffe in die region geschickt
haben muss man sich da jetzt sorgen
machen oder ist das eine militärübung
was hat das zu bedeuten
also zwei dinge das eine ist natürlich
man will die sicherheit von nancy pelosi
auch garantieren die mit dem
amerikanischen militär flugzeug nach
taiwan geflogen ist man will
sicherstellen dass sie auch heil wieder
herauskommt und das zweite ist für den
fall dass es eine eskalation gibt also
dass china möglicherweise was man hier
nicht glaubt aber vielleicht ja doch
bereit wäre taiwan anzugreifen in den
nächsten tagen und wochen dass man dann
entsprechend darauf reagieren kann diese
sorge hat man schon länger weil man eben
immer wieder diese militärischen
provokationen gesehen hat und joe biden
hat ja öffentlich in den letzten monaten
mehrfach sehr klar gemacht dass werden
die usa nicht tolerieren teil dieser
vereinbarung zwischen china und usa ist
eben genau dieser punkt dass am ende
chinesen beiderseits der straße von
taiwan friedlich und frei entscheiden
können wie sie oder wie sie nicht
zusammen leben wollen und insofern wäre
ein militärisches vorgehen eine invasion
gar eine verletzung ein bruch dieser
abmachungen und die usa das hat mir ein
hochrangiges regierungsmitglied vor
einigen wochen noch gesagt wären bereit
in diesem fall eben auch militärisch
einzuschreiten dass es anders als bei
der ukraine wo man zwar waffen liefert
sich aber sonst nach möglichkeit aus dem
konflikt unmittelbar heraushält wir
können am ende der sendung noch mal mit
dir sprechen auch über das was da jetzt
morgen geplant ist bis hierhin jetzt
erstmal vielen dank denn wir wollen
jetzt noch einmal ein bisschen tiefer in
diesen ganzen konflikt einsteigen der
ist mich sehr sehr alt schon mehrere
jahrzehnte gibt es also schon sehr lange
der tiger china konflikt und haben einen
überblick vorbereitet von franziska von
tiesenhausen
der konflikt zwischen chinas führung in
peking und taiwan schwelt seit mehr als
70 jahren der ursprung liegt im
chinesischen bürgerkrieg denen die
kommunistische partei chinas unter mao
tsetung
1949 gewann
die unterlegenen nationalisten setzten
sich nach taiwan ab im gegensatz zur
volksrepublik china auf dem festland
nannten sie die inselrepublik china mit
der hauptstadt taipeh
jahrelang haben beide seiten für sich
den anspruch erhoben formal ganz china
zu repräsentieren taiwan entwickelte
sich aber nach jahrzehnten der
militärherrschaft in den 1990 er jahren
zu einer demokratie und gab diesen
anspruch auf
peking sieht taiwan bis heute als
abtrünnige provinz präsident jean ping
sieht es als seine historische mission
an china und taiwan wieder zu vereinen
notfalls mit gewalt
wir können jetzt fragen stellen zu
diesem thema an mikro hutaree er ist der
direktor des mehr kater mehr cato
institute für china studien schönen
guten abend
wieso ist denn taiwan etwas was china so
sehr provoziert was an dem leben was an
der lebensart vielleicht was was ist es
was china da so triggert und warum ist
das also so lange schon ein
konfliktthema
um die führung in peking ist da relativ
klar das ist ein teil chinas das ist
eine abtrünnige provinz die seit
jahrzehnten sozusagen in einem status
vor sich hin manövriert den ging niemals
toleriert und es ist eine der zentralen
konflikte in der peripherie hongkong
tibet auch schön dann aufgeladen
sehr stark politisch da geht es um die
vision chinas als großmacht aufzutreten
und die eigene territoriale integrität
so wird es formuliert in eckigen dazu
nicht um jeden preis zu schützen und der
geht hier hinter die gezogene rote linie
keinen schritt zurücktreten und das
natürlich in der letzten zeit größere
selbstbewusstsein gefasst und fühlt sich
in der stärkeren position es ist ja
nicht das erste mal dass wir einen
konflikt in der taiwanstraße haben aber
die militärischen bedingungen die stärke
und machtverhältnisse haben sich
natürlich in den letzten 20 jahren
deutlich verschoben und peking sieht
sich hier in der lage jetzt auch die
eigene stärke zu demonstrieren
china hat sich auch jetzt schon dazu
geäußert zu diesem besuch eben ein video
veröffentlicht auch im vorfeld eben um
die militärische stärke zu zeigen es war
heute die rede von gezielten
militärischen aktionen die jetzt folgen
sollen was hat das alles zu bedeuten wie
würden sie das einschätzen ist china da
im ernstfall wirklich dazu bereit
wir sollten keinen zweifel daran haben
dass mittelfristig langfristig china
klar die intention hat
sich wieder einzuverleiben als teil der
volksrepublik in welcher form auch immer
ob das friedlich geschieht oder
militärisch rhetorisch sagt man
weiterhin das muss friedlich geschehen
aber es ist natürlich jetzt ein
risikopotenzial in der region stark
angewachsen der militärische kräfte sind
zusammengezogen auf allen seiten taiwan
mobilisiert durchaus
amerikanische kräfte in der region das
wird das risiko von einer
ungewollten letztlich eskalation wir
müssen uns auch darüber im klaren sein
dass moment beide seiten ihr macht
demonstrieren und säbelrasseln betreiben
nach unserer ansicht ist es nicht so
dass wir hier unmittelbar mit einer
kriegerischen auseinandersetzung rechnen
sollten aber es ist eben eine situation
wo keiner einen schritt zurücktritt und
in so einer spiraldynamik kann natürlich
einiges passieren und jetzt ist nancy
pelosi ja nicht die us präsidentin sie
ist die vorsitzende des
repräsentantenhauses aber wieso wird das
jetzt auch schon als ein so provokanter
besuch gesehen von seiten chinas
und formal ist sie natürlich die
dritthöchste der präsidentin des staates
ist und insofern fühlt sich die führung
müßig zu sagen das ist ein staatsbesuch
umgekehrt betont die amerikanische seite
es ist in einer tradition von kongress
besuchen dann sind das natürlich
interpretations fragen letztlich geht es
darum dass sich in den letzten jahren
auf allen seiten sozusagen schritte
angedeutet haben die eben weniger
kompromissfähigkeit zeigen auf seiten
der usa ist dass immer weniger sagen
eine politik der
unklarheit die man gegenüber taiwan und
china dort vertritt also eine klare
commitments ein bestätigung auch der
unterstützung taiwans auf der seite
chinas seit vielen jahren wurde der
druck erhöht militärisch
wirtschaftspolitisch im internationalen
raum und auch auf seiten teil er ist
natürlich die führung derzeit bemüht
sich klar zu machen das ist hier
keinesfalls kompromisse geben kann mit
blick auf die frage wie tätigen hier
seine eigenen interessen durchsetzt kann
also ich glaube alle seiten sind ja gut
beraten einen schritt zurückzutreten
aber letztlich ist klar die
volksrepublik dreht hier an der spirale
die amerikaner versuchen hier
insbesondere auf der kongress seite ein
starkes zeichen zu setzen dass die
unterstützung für taiwan da ist und auch
immer da bleiben wird wir müssen
vielleicht auch noch mal ganz konzept
sich auch was klären es gibt hier
nämlich eine frage bei youtube von bach
erfragt deutschland hat japan noch nicht
als eigenständiges land anerkannt oder
und das gilt ja auch für viele andere
länder auch für die usa vielleicht
könnten sie uns hier noch mal ein
bisschen hintergrundinformationen geben
wieder der status quo ist es ist richtig
staaten haben die anerkennung teil 1
gewechselt zur volksrepublik china
1972 die 50 jahre deutschen jesus
beziehungen mit der volksrepublik stehen
anders ab jahren hintergrund vorher
wurde da zumindest von einigen staaten
teilnahmen anerkannt also in der tat
kein europäischer staat auch nicht die
usa das wurde jetzt zuletzt auch noch
mal von der administration bestätigt es
geht nicht darum dass die unabhängigkeit
taiwans hier sozusagen
erreicht werden soll es geht um den
status quo und der status quo bedeutet
eben das ist eine gewisse unklarheit mit
blick auf die zukunft gibt ihn nur
taiwan und auch und die taiwanische
bevölkerung mit bestimmten darauf und
insofern militärischen und nicht als
politisch verschiebung der lage oder der
versuch eben hier einseitig eine
veränderung herbeizuführen durch druck
insbesondere auf seiten der
volksrepublik ist etwas was nicht
toleriert werden
ein thema was viele hier auch in den
kommentaren interessiert ich komme auch
gleich zu den fragen dazu ist das teil
aber tatsächlich trotz seiner größe das
ist ja sehr sehr klein aber
wirtschaftlich enorme auswirkungen hat
denn experten und expertinnen experten
gehen außerdem davon aus dass wenn es
dort zu einer militärischen eskalation
kommen sollte dass eben größere
auswirkungen haben könnte als jetzt
gerade der russische krieg in der
ukraine allein schon auf uns alle hat
wir haben dazu auch mal ein paar fakten
zusammengetragen das ist wichtig zu
wissen china ist mit einem anteil weil
das wäre ja auch ein konflikt partner
von rund 11,8 prozent an den
gesamtimporten deutschlands damit ist es
größter import partner eben und zum
vergleich taiwan liegt mit gut einem
prozent zwar auf platz 25 aber eben
dieses kleine land hat eine große
bedeutung denn es ist unser wichtiger
exportpartner für die chip produktion
und das bringt mich dazu dass einige von
euch sich auch genau diese fragen
stellen hat ein konflikt dort eben auch
eine eskalation dort auswirkungen auf
uns zum beispiel oliver möchte bei
youtube wissen deutsche investitionen in
china die steigen immer mehr falls es
eine krise zwischen china und taiwan
geben sollte wohin geht dieser situation
wie geht die reise dann weiter haben sie
da antworten für oliver rong und andere
und erstmal ist klar dass die politik
zunehmend damit ich meine ich die
deutsche und die europäische politik
signale sende wie sie mit so einer krise
umgehen würde wenn sie dann militärisch
eskaliert von seiten der volksrepublik
betrieben die aussenministerin hatte
gesagt auch der europäische außen-
vertreter haben signalisiert dass wir
dann in einen see sanktion szenario
auslaufen würden und habe parallelen
gezogen zu den
europäischen sanktionen gegenüber
russland aufgrund des angriffskriegs in
der ukraine und das hätte dramatische
auswirkungen für die deutsche und
europäische volkswirtschaft in der tat
müssten viele unternehmen sich dann
überlegen haben ob sie weiterhin in
china produzieren operieren können und
da die deutschland insbesondere so
verflochten ist mit der volksrepublik
hätte das durchaus sehr direkt und weit
reichende folgen für die deutsche
volkswirtschaft
haben sie denn vielleicht können sie das
mal für uns einordnen was sehen sie
jetzt gerade als die größeren bedrohung
oder was hat das für kurzfristige
konsequenzen dieser besucher jetzt was
kann es für welche haben was hat es aber
vielleicht auch für mittelfristige
konsequenzen dazu passt nämlich auch die
frage von annika die hat per mail
geschrieben ich möchte wissen welche
rolle der konflikt im südchinesischen
meer bei dem konflikt um taiwan spielt
dieser betrifft ja noch deutlich mehr
länder in der region aber vielleicht
trennen wir es zuerst so vielleicht
zunächst einmal kurzfristige
mittelfristige konsequenzen was könnte
das bedeuten
kurzfristig ist klar es geht erstmal
darum dass die chinesische seite
angelegt hat jetzt sogenannte live
exercises um die insel herum
durchzuführen da geht es darum zu prüfen
ob die zusagen historisch angelegt sind
ich gehe davon aus dass einige grenzen
überschritten werden also die gebiete wo
die stattfinden sollen dem sehr nah an
der insel taiwan dran wir hatten 1996
auch raketenabschüsse über taiwan alle
solche dinge wenn sie passieren würden
wieder werden ein klares zeichen dass
peking hier mit aller macht seine stärke
demonstrieren will und dann wird zu
beobachten sein dass man erst mal wieder
sozusagen deeskaliert hoffentlich aus
dieser krise heraus dass alle seiten
einen weg zurück finden
das jetzt nicht als einen dauerhaften
zustand zu halten ist scheint offene
kanäle auf allen seiten zu geben das
telefonat zwischen sieben und torheiten
präsident joe biden in den usa ist auch
deshalb so wichtig gewesen in den
letzten wochen
und das ist die kurzfristige lage wir
dürfen nicht vergessen auch in decken
jetzt gerade eine besondere politische
zeit im august finden häufig
führungstreffen statt die pilotfolge
teilen sony hat da ein wichtiges
jubiläum zu feiern eine höchst
angespannte lage vor dem 20
parteikongress ende dieses jahres im
oktober voraussichtlich also politisch
sensibel da gilt das jetzt erstmal die
spannung wieder runter zu fangen
mittelfristig ist klar und das ist
vielleicht das was am meisten uns
herausfordern wird die spannungen
zwischen den usa und china werden sich
verschärfen es gibt hier keinerlei
anzeichen dass beide seiten von ihren
positionen zurücktreten würden und
insofern müssen wir damit rechnen dass
nicht nur solche besucher vielleicht
regelmäßiger stattfinden sondern auch
dass der militärische druck und der
wirtschaftspolitische druck auf thailand
von seiten der volksrepublik dramatisch
hochgefahren werden wird und da wir sie
als china experten jetzt auch gerade bei
uns haben dann auch eben gerne noch die
ihr von mir eben schon angesprochene
frage von annika per mail die fragte
sich eben der konflikt im
südchinesischen meer da geht es ja um
kämpfer um fischer gründe fischerei
gründe öl gas reserven wie der sich noch
weiterentwickeln könnte sie schrieb
zurecht dieser betrifft ja noch deutlich
mehr länder in der region
in diesem konflikt arenen sind durchaus
miteinander verknüpft nicht zuletzt
daraus ansprüche erhebt auch einige
dieser inseln in der region am man auch
jetzt gesehen schon die flugroute von
nancy pelosi in ganz absichtlich
natürlich um dieses südchinesischen meer
herum weil dort in den letzten jahren
china durchaus kapazitäten aufgebaut hat
auch militärisch sensorik flüge zu
verfolgen oder auch abwehrraketen zu
positionen also eine verschränkung
dieser konflikte liegt auf der hand
alles das was in der region passiert hat
unmittelbare auswirkungen auch auf die
frage wie sich zukünftig als demokratie
in der region halten kann
danke für ihre einschätzung heute abend
ein mikrofon tahri vom meer cato
institute für china studies dankeschön
und
wir können noch mal sprechen jetzt mit
unserem korrespondenten in den usa mit
el mati wissen denn in nancy pelosi es
reise- und auch ihre ankunft in taiwan
ist ja gerade erst erfolgt sie hat also
morgen ja auch noch einen ganzen tag vor
sich immer was steht denn dabei nancy
pelosi auf dem programm was ist da der
grund für ihre reise eigentlich
das hochrangigste treffen dann auch mit
der präsidentin von taiwan die frei
gewählt wurde in den letzten monaten und
das heißt im umkehrschluss natürlich
auch ein signal dass man zeigt dass man
auf oberster ebene miteinander redet
wenn ich da will ich mal noch ein
bisschen was erklären aus den letzten
monaten wie sich das immer wieder
hochgeschaukelt hat wir haben letztes
jahr im oktober beispielsweise
situationen gehabt da ist china mit über
50 kampfjets tatsächlich in diese
militär freie zone die neutrale zone
rund um taiwan eingedrungen da hätte es
beinahe auch eine eskalation schon
gegeben daraufhin hat joe biden aus dem
weißen haus mit jean ping telefoniert
man hat sich darauf verständigt dass man
gegenseitig diese ein-china-politik
respektiert und den status nicht
verändern will und wenige tage danach
hat jean ping dann auf einem kongress
eine flammende rede gehalten und klar
gemacht nicht verhandlungsbereit taiwan
gehört zu china und am ende werden die
die sich der flut der geschichte
entgegen stellen so hat er das
formuliert in diesen fluten untergehen
elendiglich zugrunde gehen und das zeigt
den brunnen dass in diesem punkt
eigentlich gar keine lösung möglich ist
aus chinesischer sicht irgendwann diese
wiedervereinigung wieder herbei zu
führen und die usa gingen eigentlich
davon aus dass es den showdown um das
ganze vielleicht in ein paar jahren gibt
weil china militärisch noch nicht so in
der lage ist der amerikanischen militär
macht und vor allen dingen seinen
verbündeten in der region zu widerstehen
aber jetzt deutet sich eben an dass man
vielleicht dieses doch als anlass nehmen
könnte
und hier in washington wird vermutet
dass hat ein stück weit auch mit dem
ukrainer krieg zu tun was ist denn die
lehrer aus der ukraine
dass man wenn man militärisch
erfolgreich sein will vielleicht lieber
früher als später mit seiner
militärmacht die man zu dem zeitpunkt
hat gegen einen ein inselstaat wie in
diesem fall dann taiwan vorgeht bevor
taiwan noch weiter hoch gerüstet wird
durch die usa und durch ihre verbündeten
also die situation ist schon brenzlig
aber man hofft natürlich dass da die
beiden ja miteinander sprechen jinping
und joe biden man auch in der lage ist
in den nächsten tagen möglicherweise
über telefonate miteinander irgendeiner
beruhigung der situation hin zu bekommen
glaubst du also nicht dass das jetzt zu
einer verschlechterung zwischen den
beziehungen zwischen den usa und china
führen könnte
also momentan denkt man im weißen haus
beide seiten haben eben zu viel zu
verlieren also china ist in
wirtschaftslehre wirtschaftlichen
schwierigkeiten sie jean ping will im
november ja unbedingt in der partei
bestätigt werden eine weitere amtszeit
bekommen und da kann er eigentlich
keinen großen konflikte brauchen weil
eben ein krieg im indopazifik am ende
auch massive wirtschaftliche
auswirkungen auf china haben würde
natürlich auch auf die usa und die
verbündeten in der jeweiligen region
aber man kann im grunde genommen diese
eskalation zur zeit einfach nicht
gebrauchen und china ist militärisch
auch noch nicht so stark das ist eben
dem amerikanischen der amerikanischen
flotte der navy wirklich ausreichend
widerstehen könnte hat aber in den
letzten jahren massiv nachgerüstet hat
die raketen modernisiert hat atomraketen
für u-boote weiterentwickelt und
ähnliches getan das heißt man rechnet
hier in washington eigentlich schon
lange damit dass man irgendwann an den
punkt kommt wo eine militärische
konfrontation unvermeidlich ist aber man
hat gedacht man kann auch angesichts der
großen probleme in der welt
wirtschaftspolitische probleme pandemien
aber auch der kampf gegen den
klimawandel
dass man in all diesen punkten zusammen
arbeiten kann statt sich gegenseitig im
grunde genommen ja im grunde genommen
ein stück weit die die zukunft zu
verbauen wenn man eben in einen großen
militärischen konflikten erschüttert
sagt unser korrespondent in den usa
matti wissen danke für die einschätzung
heute abend und du hast das natürlich
auch das treffen morgen das treffen
zwischen der präsidentin und nancy
pelosi in teheran für uns im blick und
für heute sagen wir danke danke an die
ich immer und auch danke natürlich an
euch für eure fragen und kommentare bis
zum nächsten mal